yeah I mean
a drag factor
really so you're getting more early
well well
yeah
I I keep trying new ways to get here
sometimes it takes me longer yeah
I'm late so it was probably a couple
minutes longer okay so good morning
everyone and welcome to the first
session of today Workshop
so uh our first session will be by uh
John Owens he is a professor from the
Department of electrical engine
electrical and computer engineering from
UC Davis and uh John Devin John Owens is
a Pioneer in fundamental algorithm and
data structure in GPT GPU Computing and
um yeah let's the
I'm looking forward for your talk thanks
a lot
hi good morning Mike cool okay
um I'm excited to be here uh coming to
an audience of theorists is always
really exciting because some of my
favorite work that I've done has been
getting to collaborate with theorists
and I am by no means a theorist myself
but I learn a lot from all of you and I
think there are really wonderful
collaborations uh with people
um just as a trigger warning
um you know some of the things that I
will say from a theory point of view are
going to make you feel kind of creepy
because we do some things that you're
going to say holy cow that is like
so far off what we should be doing and
some of these things we do for good
reasons but you might even have better
reasons we should do them in a different
way
um so as I've talked to people and seen
these talks uh you know I came here
thinking that this talk would be all
about like the details of doing dynamic
graphs but uh and how we do them on gpus
but I'm going to say that's actually a
pretty small fraction of the talk uh the
picture that I'm getting is it's going
to be a better opportunity for me
um to give maybe a little bit of a
bigger picture about the way we think
and some of the constraints we have so
that you understand where we're coming
from and that you know maybe we can have
some of the same vocabulary
um so the data structure kind of stuff
that I have done has been in
collaboration with theorists uh the our
group built the first uh uh data or
sorry the first hash tables that could
be built on the GPU and that was a
cuckoo hashing construction
um and then more recently I've been
collaborating with Martin Farish Colton
and we've done a lot of the first
Dynamic data structures on gpus and
that's relatively recent work and we've
built a whole bunch of stuff and I've
really enjoyed these collaborations
um one thing that I really want to point
out on this slide though is that when we
look at sort of when the work was done
in the theory Community when cuckoo
hashing was uh first described
and then when we actually did it on the
GPU or when bucketing for instance is a
hash table technique was done versus
when we were able to put it on the GPU
there's a big time Gap there I mean it
takes a while for your great ideas to
percolate into our community and that's
why I really want to emphasize there's a
lot of opportunities there
um you know I'm excited by some of the
stuff that I've seen this week and I
think you should feel uh open to tell
people in our community hey these are
you know really exciting things that are
happening and you know what does this
look like on on your kind of platform
so I want to note what's different for
me as a systems person than you as a
theorist like what do we think about
when we want research contributions and
probably the number one thing is we want
to build something and then we want to
evaluate it and how do we evaluate it
and your evaluation is like well we had
this bounds and we made it better or we
had this bounds and we made it tighter
and it's a very cut and dried kind of
thing for us we kind of have different
goals we're less interested in the uh
you know the theoretical running time as
we are in the actual running time and so
we try to make things faster and then we
try to do things that couldn't be done
before
um but for us we're I don't want to do
work that is a solution in search of a
problem and there's a lot of research
out there that is well I built this
thing but I don't really know what it's
for and so we're actually really trying
to you know we believe that systems work
can be used to solve real problems
there's a lot of good real problems out
there so we look for both problems and
data sets that people care about in the
field
um the other thing is there's a lot of
systems work out there at least that I
review and it's a little bit frustrating
when it's like I did this uh it's like I
built this thing and here's how I built
it and that is not really what we want
to see in our community and just to know
what we do want to see there's a really
wonderful post by Kayvon fatahallian
who's a a professor at Stanford and we
overlapped in grad school which is kind
of fun really really sharp guy and he
talks about the characteristics of good
systems papers and the things that I
really want to emphasize are one of the
important things is to say hey we built
this but here were our choices okay we
could have done this and this and this
and we tried this and it was a bad idea
and we think this is a bad idea so we
didn't pursue it and this is why we got
to where we are equally important is
constraints to say here are the
constraints on our problem because then
somebody can come back and look at your
design decisions and your constraints
and maybe those are different in their
scenario but at least they can see what
your thinking was and build on that and
it's just much more important than I
built this
so how do you get started as a theorist
starting to think about this
um if you can come and say look here's
this problem of practical interest
that's something that we really love to
hear
um and I think you know all these things
and I'm hearing all these data
structures and like constructions and
like they're really complicated and most
of what you know is not known to our
community so if you come in and say you
know this work was really exciting that
we did and is this something that we can
you know put into practice uh there's
this other work that's out here and like
everybody's excited about it in my
community this is maybe something that
uh you know again could be put into
practice and then to sit down and sort
of think about what the constraints are
Well turns out if we use this technique
it really requires X and Y and that's
not great for your Target but there's
this other way to do things and it only
requires Z and maybe that's a good and
so those are the sort of conversations
that I have when we get started
um talking to therus
but I do want to emphasize like the gap
between all the wonderful beautiful
algorithms and data structures that you
build and what's actually been put
together in the field and what's
actually being used is large and I
really do think there's a lot of
opportunity
okay so I'm going to spend the next
little bit uh sort of telling you how
gpus work at a high level
um and so some of this is just to
introduce some terminology but uh just
to say how we think about problems so
what does this machine look like that
we're looking at
so this is sort of the one slide what is
the the programming model for in this
case nvidia's Cuda and it's sort of the
dominant way that you program gpus but
there's other fairly similar
interfaces that can be done
um but uh generally what you do is you
start off with a CPU that has a lot of
data on it maybe attached in a disk
maybe in the cpu's memory and you take
that data and you move it over to the
GPU and then you call what are called
kernels on the GPU perhaps this series
of kernels and it's going to operate on
this data and the GPU has its own memory
right so it's got this really big really
it's not really big has a relatively
small very fast fairly expensive memory
and it does all of the work in its own
memory so it'll churn through this for a
while and then when you're done you take
the data and you bring it back so it is
a co-processor and it's under the
direction of a CPU
so what is these what are these kernels
like when we do compute what does that
actually look like so we call a kernel
over a grid and so a grid is one two or
three dimensional you get to decide as
the programmer and it's a grid of blocks
okay and each block is again something
that you get to Define in terms of the
dimensionality and size but it's a group
of threads okay so grid is a grid of
blocks block is a big group of threats
right and so each thread knows it's its
identity it knows uh uh how big blocks
are how big grids are and so on so it's
a little bit like a pram kind of model
because what you're going to do is
you're going to write one program that
ones runs on one of these threads and
the hardware will run the same program
on every thread and so they can
cooperate in interesting ways and the
distinction between having this little
two level structure of grids to blocks
blocks two threads is that threads
within a block can cooperate in a way
that threads across blocks cannot
are there some strong restrictions about
this same program assumption like you
know you can always say the program is
if I'm Fred zero run a if I'm third one
and again like in principle you could
trade you throughout this but is this
maybe enforce it as strongly yeah so the
question is uh could I have you know we
think about taking the same same program
and running it on every single thread
what kind of differentiation can we do
between threads and so yes you can
absolutely write a program that says
every thread with an odd ID do this
every thread with an even ID do this the
programming model there is called spemd
single program multiple data now there's
some efficiency issues with that but
absolutely you can have branches in that
program and those branches can be based
on which thread or blocker so on
so um
getting cold break others cannot but go
to the grid schedule right so the
question is uh threads within the same
block can cooperate uh blocks are
independent the grid is the overall data
structure that says this is the number
of blocks that I have in their
dimensionality and span okay so you
launch a a kernel over one grid
that grid says hey I've got a bunch of
blocks and then each block has a certain
dimensionality there's lots of
restrictions in here so for instance you
can't have more than a fixed number of
threads within a block right so it's not
arbitrary but what this says is that uh
threads within a block have a lot of
locality and can cooperate at a very
fine grain level does that answer your
question
bring the money group 2 is just
parallelism uh no this is uh grid one
and grid two is just parallel no kernel
one will launch over a grid that it
specifies kernel two we'll then launch
over a different grid this is a
computational structure it's not a data
structure it's just saying I'm launching
a million you know a thousand blocks
Each of which has a thousand threads in
it
we're trying to solve one problem with
multiple kernels right perhaps yes so
why do I have an advantage of using
multiple kernels versus using one kernel
with many more blocks uh well uh
they could be sequential like hey I have
to calculate this thing first and then
calculate this thing second and this
grid and this grid need to be different
dimensionality because of your problem
it might be that this it makes more
sense to fuse them out you know like
that's a fission kind of problem right
like a compiler sometimes will split
into this so
um you know if your mental model is I
just call one giant kernel over this
huge grid that's totally fine but with
the ability to do multiple in sequence
so I know maybe
again so there is an implicit Global
barrier between kernels and that's
another reason you split things into
kernels so it basically says everything
here must finish before it does here
uh within a block you can call a barrier
synchronization okay so you can say all
the threads need to arrive at this place
before any of them move forward and that
is a low-cost thing to do a global
barrier is pretty expensive but within a
block you can have a synchronization
then you have a top you know I say that
these need to be independent and they
are they can't be dependent on each
other in the sense that this can't be
waiting for this to finish because they
can run in an arbitrary order
but you can do things like atomics that
these share so he could be incrementing
a counter while you know she is checking
account or incrementing it herself does
that make sense
okay
it's a timeline so kernel one finished
before
so uh right so could could I launch
multiple kernels in parallel yes I can
there is capability on the hardware to
do that
um there are reasons to do it but in
general
um
the normal way is to say run this then
run this because there's not really an
advantage in running two of them next to
each other like all you're doing is
splitting things in space instead of
time so it is straightforward to be able
to write code in this way and people
think in a sequential light but there is
ways to have multiple things happening
at the same time just to cover it in
these do not represent different chunks
of the hardware
these are these are uh so do these
represent different chunks of the
hardware so I'm going to show the
hardware on the next slide uh this
represents this kernel using the entire
Hardware to run over this grid and then
this you know this finishes everything's
done and then this uses the entire
Hardware to do it again
okay good okay
so
um cool so this gives we have a lot of
parallelism here okay we have
parallelism across blocks and blocks can
run in an arbitrary order there's no
enforcement on that by the hardware at
all uh and then there's parallelism
within a block okay and so your mental
model is that you literally have
hundreds of thousands millions of
threads in flight at a time in fact the
latest hardware and I'll show the stat a
little bit is that to keep the hardware
busy on the latest GPU you have 300 000
threads that are literally in flight at
any given time like are in registers so
that's a lot of threads there's a lot of
stuff happening at the same time and the
programming model exposes that by
letting you express parallelism across
spreads a class rocks and across threads
within a block
okay
so the the thing that I want you to take
into the next slide is there's
parallelism across these blocks okay and
when we launch a grid we're saying hey
here's this big collection of blocks
and then the hardware has cores okay and
they're called SMS streaming
multiprocessors and in this case this GP
is 144 cores
okay so the job of the hardware the
primary job of the square is to take a
block
and assign it to a core so you might
launch a kernel that has 10 000 blocks
in it
and then the hardware is responsible to
dealing those out to cores okay so every
time a core becomes idle the hardware
will give it another block give it
another block give it another block
Hardware's really good at this it keeps
the hardware busy all the time and if we
go back a slide the right way to think
about what a block is is it's a virtual
core right your mental picture is if I
want to launch 10 000 blocks I think
about having a GPU with 10 000 cores
there's only 144 cores and the hardware
sort of de-virtualizes that okay
so what that makes because these blocks
are independent they don't depend on
each other it means that you can take a
program you write here and run it
efficiently on a GPU that has two cores
or 144 cores and it'll just run faster
if it has 144 cores if you've exposed
enough parallelism within the program
then it will run efficiently on large or
small gpus and that's really the biggest
thing they tried to do with this
programming model there's a lot of
explicit parallelism but it scales
nicely
okay so I will talk about the memory
system I will talk about it here so let
me tell you what's in each of these
cores right so this is this big GPU if
you want to like hoard things right now
this is a really good thing to do uh
they're extremely expensive and hard to
get like because they're in enormous
demand everybody wants them in their
data centers and videos making scads of
money because they've done a great job
building these gpus so what we have here
is 144 cores this big blue things here
is a level two cache that is shared
among all of these cores and then
there's a memory interface that goes out
to dram and all of them share the same
memory interface so they have one pool
of dram that's outside here okay
um there is an enormous amount of
computer so uh you know double Precision
or single Precision floating Point uh
dozens of teraflops okay which is a ton
of flaps uh if you are doing
specifically deep learning kind of math
uh and you can structure your stuff in
like little 4x4 dense Matrix matrices
then you can get you know an order of
magnitude more because of special
purpose Hardware to support that there
is uh on the highest end gpus 80
gigabytes and that's relatively small
compared to what you can get on a CPU
amount of dram but a really high
bandwidth to that TV room they use hbm
uh this type band with memory it's small
because you need that to make it run
fast but that is a lot of uh of of uh
bandwidth and then they're gradually
adding new instructions new hardware to
be able to do cool stuff so in this
latest one for instance there's Hardware
to accelerate dynamic programming that
they say well uh has a 7x speed up over
the way that they did things before
okay so what's actually in each of these
cores so I sort of zoom in on that
little core here and here's what it
looks like and so what it is is this
giant sea of uh floating Point units
okay and it has integer math as well but
you're going to see each of these little
boxes is a different ALU there's a whole
bunch of 32-bit whole bunch of 64-bit
this is integer math here there's this
big register file which I'll talk about
in a little bit uh there is Hardware
that does this tensor operation that's
really uh optimized for deep learning
training
um and then uh there is a pool of uh
cash okay and so this is the next part
of the memory system we have a pool of
cash here that's shared within a core
that can be used as basically a scratch
Pad memory so you can either use
Hardware supported like level one style
cache or you can configure it to be just
a big array that you get to manage any
way you want okay so you just you
literally declare an array and you get
to populate it okay and that's shared by
all the threads within a single block
okay that's the hardware look there's
lots of stuff in it it's giant um and uh
it's a lot of fun to program because you
just have an enormous amount of compute
at your disposal
is demon possible maybe I can move
offline but just is it possible to say
that some of it is an array that I can
control and some of it is left for cash
yes so the question is uh this 256
kilobyte L1 data cache slash shared
memory you get to sort of draw the line
between them so you don't get an
arbitrary place to draw that but you do
get to there's some places where you can
say make this mostly L1 or make this
mostly the shared memory that you can
configure
foreign
okay so just to look at the memory
system because this is kind of wonky
compared to uh
uh compared to I think traditional CPU
memory systems where you have sort of
this uh you know things as you go
farther away get much bigger and much
slower
um
so first we'll look at the memory so uh
Global memory that all threads can
access okay up to 80 gigabytes which is
again pretty small compared to the CPU
world you can buy a CPU with like a five
terabyte memory system so this is a big
limitation then we have a big pool of
shared L2 cache okay per block okay
within a block you have 256 kilobytes
and so uh you can configure that any way
you want and so if we aggregate that
over all the SMS that's 36 megabytes of
cache see look at this and like this is
only a little bit smaller of L1 than you
have an L2 and it's not typical CPU
memory system
uh warps or something I'm not going to
talk about right at the moment but then
uh we have registers okay uh and that's
a lot of registers the idea to have
dozens of megabytes of registers is very
strange right with 30 megabytes of
registers
the reason for this is because if you
want to have a lot of threads in flight
at a time
okay then you need to be able to store
those threads and so the fundamental
thing that a GPU does different than a
CPU is that a CPU will try to minimize
latency right so there's all these
things on a CPU that minimize latency
like Branch prediction or caches or you
know value prediction or you know tons
of little things out of order execution
and so on they're trying to minimize
latency as much as they can GPS tolerate
latency they say you know what we've got
this long latency so we're going to run
until we stall and then we're going to
switch over to another thread and run
until we stall and switch over to
another thread and run until we stall
and by the time we're done with all
those threads and we get back to the
first one hopefully that long latency
operation has completed
okay the only way you can do that is by
having lots of threads in flight at a
time so you can switch and it's very
efficient to switch between threads but
it means you need this giant boatload of
registers to be able to make that work
right so that is just a get out of town
amount of registers
okay
this is
uh right so the question is does the
system need all these storage it's
saying that if I launch 300 000 threads
each of those and each of those threads
is resident can run on the next cycle it
means that I need registers to be able
to store them so when we look at you
know this big block diagram uh this
register file this block here just
physically it's very large and it's able
to store you know within a core 2000
threads in flight at a time yeah but can
you if you don't have as many thread
screen you use it for other things I
mean I'm just you know say well why
don't they make it twice as big so I get
some registers as well for my program
yeah
so
um so the question is could we use them
for something else so yes uh
uh their only accessed as register so
you don't get like indirect access to
them that's maybe more detail than I
want to go into right now
um I'm going to say that registers are
often a precious resource so uh you know
every you know if I want to fill the
machine then every thread gets no more
than 32 registers which is not a lot
okay but yes we we do try to use them
for all sorts of creative things and we
do a lot of thread coarsening where we
say oh this thread should run two or
four or eight things and so that'll take
more registers as well but that's kind
of an offline question
okay yes
is there an issue of fault tolerance
here like two pieces uh fall tolerance
yeah does fall tolerance come up with
all those threads is that I mean
so I'm going to say short answer no uh
long answer maybe a little bit in the
sense that uh Nvidia will turn off some
of the cores if they're broken in any
way so if you go buy a cheaper GPU it's
a more expensive GPU or some of the
cores failed
um but uh I'm not aware of like Dynamic
things that are like that so
okay uh
uh the other thing I'm
going to mutation hierarchy here and the
thing that I really you know we had we
talked about kernels and blocks and
threads uh the thing I really want to
mention though is this idea of warps
because this is important so the actual
atom that gets run in here
is 32 atoms that are in simd lockstep
okay so every time it issues an
instruction what it's issuing is 32
threads that are all running together
okay this is called a warp you can think
of this 32 wide Vector okay and that
thing runs in lockstep in the sense that
if you want to Branch then it can't run
both sides of the branch at a time if
you say even threads do this odd threads
do this what's going to happen is the
odd threads run and the even threads are
asleep and then it switches so it's
important to make the most of the
hardware to try to minimize that
Divergence and we spend a lot of time
trying to craft algorithms so that it
does minimize that Divergence and then
some workloads this isn't a problem at
all if you're doing dense matrix
multiplication everything's sort of
doing the same thing but the the
workloads that have the most throughput
minimize Divergence here but this warp
is important
okay uh so what matters when we're
thinking about doing computation okay so
the most important thing is filling the
machine right this machine can have 300
000 threads and flight at a time if
you're only launching 50 000 threads
most of your machine is going to be idle
so we need problems that will allow us
to be big enough to have a lot of
threads and I want to keep those threads
busy all the time
we want to avoid Divergence and compute
especially at this 7032 neighboring
threads level right if they're all
branching in a different direction if 32
threads all branch in a different
direction we have a 32x slow down there
um contention turns out to be pretty
important like we see data structures
that uh that don't think about
contention at the scale of hundreds of
thousands of things banging on a lock at
the same time and so we did some work on
building up B trees and when we took to
sort of this normal like classic beetry
thing compared it and implemented that
on the GPU and compared it to how we did
it when you know we implemented in a
very GPU friendly way that was a factor
of a thousand and it was mostly because
of contention right just we had lots of
threads waiting for other threads to
finish and so thinking about problems at
this scale of concurrency is not
something that's traditionally done in
the CPU world foreign
what is contention again contention
meaning like I've got a lock okay or
latch or whatever it happens to be and
only one thread can own this lock or
latch whatever at a time and a bunch of
other threads are waiting for it so when
that's the case you're setting idle
you're not doing anything so we try to
design things to minimize that just to
clarify you took a standard CPU
Implement you took the standard CPU
implementation ran on the GPU no it's
not like a single threaded thing we took
a design that would be sort of your
textbook B tree okay and said this is
how you do it this is your latching
strategy this is when you split nodes
and so on and then we implemented that
and then we said okay now let's think
about how to do this in the GPU and
there was a lot of hey we'll give you
extra you know we'll trade computation
for contention we'll do extra
computation to avoid contention okay so
so you can Implement a relatively
straightforward fashion but on the GPU
yes a baseline in a parallel way in a
parallel way right
okay
do you have like uh
the comics semantics similar to what our
GPU offers uh CPU yes and then if so we
have autonomics yes and then do you
think that a concurrent data structures
that that do not use any locks May
translate in an a nicer way to add to a
GPU because of that
um
I don't think they're appreciably
different like I mean you know we're not
implementing these in this weird GPU way
like our locks look like your locks but
if you have 299 000 threads banging on
them then that's a lot of loss of
concurrency so basically you're saying
that concurrent like data structures
which are concurrent by Design may be
GPU friendly right yeah okay yeah yeah
but even then there's a lot of
algorithmic engineering involved in
taking a CPU B tree design and making it
more GPU friendly you know we got a
really nice paper out of this and I
think the the what we've learned about
concurrency is broadly valuable
okay
um cool
uh memory wise you know we spend a lot
of time and I'm sure you do too thinking
about how you can use the lowest levels
of the memory hierarchy or the closest
levels of the memory hierarchy
um one thing that's very important and
this is not GPU specific but it's dram
specific when you out when you touch a
line of dram basically you're paying the
cost of I touch one bit in that line I
paid for the entire line that's the way
dram Works what this means in terms of
How It's implemented on the GPU is that
you've got 32 threads in lockstep and
they all go out to Dram at the same time
okay and they all touch the same line
that's the same cost as if one of them
touches one word in that line once you
touch that line you've paid for the
whole line so you really want to
structure your memory accesses so you've
got a whole warp accessing things next
to each other and then that's how you
get full bandwidth and we call this
coalescing and this is somewhat similar
to the external memory model
um one thing that doesn't really
used at least in our community and maybe
you can help us use it better is L2
cache This Global cache which is really
big uh in the sense of like really using
that efficiently and the reason is
because if you look at the number of
threads you run on the CPU
compared to the amount of L2 or L3 there
is in a CPU each thread kind of owns
tens or hundreds of kilobytes right
there's a fairly large working set that
each thread gets because you've got you
know 32 threads maybe running on a CPU
like everybody gets a fair amount of
space when you have 300 000 threads
running at a time even with a 50
megabyte L2 you're only having a few
hundred bytes per thread and it's harder
to take advantage of what is really a
very small thread allocation so the
places where we've seen this be useful
is when all the threads need the same
thing right so in our B tree
implementation turned out to be nice
because B tree should be good in terms
of taking the upper levels of B tree
storing them in cash and then lots of
threads want to access them and it turns
out that worked in practice but most of
the time this was so small that we don't
really get to take good advantage of it
um
okay so I don't know models like you
guys know models
um but here's some of the things we
think about GPU dram is relatively small
you probably think about external memory
models being with more memory and we
don't do a lot of work Beyond GPU dram
most of the work when we scale to
multiple gpus is honestly that we say 80
gigabytes isn't enough so we're going to
use eight gpus because that multiplies
the amount of memory by eight uh which
is kind of a crummy way to do it but
that's what we end up doing and there
hasn't been a ton of at least
interesting academic work in terms of
how do we extend this to CPUs and disks
and so on
um but it is like the external memory
model in terms of how we access dram
this idea of coalescing being really
really important but it turns out most
applications in the GPU world end up
being bandwidth bound there is so much
compute here right it's hard to build
something that ends up being compute
bound because we have so much compute
what do you mean by limited
I'm saying like that seems really
important and I don't think there's a
ton of academic work out there that does
like oh here's this interesting insight
about how we can use the CPU as this
backing store and use disk and so on
like
um there's not a lot of GPU specific
work there so there's good Systems
Support for
um you know having a unified memory
system and doing automatic paging but
it's not something academics have really
touched and if there's good ideas that
we could have there I would love to hear
them you mean the combination you mean
the combination of CPU and GPU Yeah okay
or CPU GPU and disk or CPU and GPU and
you know like there's a lot of practical
things that have been done I just
haven't seen a lot of like oh here's
this really great idea that academics
came up with
um and then finally like
you know I get asked all the time like I
want to build this GPU thing uh I don't
really know much about GPS what's the
model I should use and the problem is
it's really complicated to program GPU
as well there's so many things you have
to juggle there's all these weird
corners and so
like
every time people say oh I'm going to
use this model and say well it doesn't
account for this this or this and the
intersection between like things you
know and things that I find useful ends
up being like really small and it's sad
and it's our fault because we built this
really complicated GPU
um but I I don't have a good answer when
people say like what's the model that I
should think about which is unfortunate
and I don't know that there's a solution
for this problem it doesn't like there's
this Magic model out there that takes
into account all the things we think are
important when we write programs
foreign
all right now I'm going to talk just a
little bit about sort of how things have
changed over the last few years and this
is going to get the graphs eventually I
promise
um so I've only had one sabbatical where
I went and did something cool and that
was in 2012 and I worked at Twitter for
six months and it was awesome and I
spent a lot of my time saying look
you've got all these big complicated
pipelines and they all run on the CPU
and maybe there's this thing we can do
in this pipeline that's like on the GPU
and it's like a lot faster than you can
do on the CPU and maybe you could think
about moving it over and this was a
really hard sell to make because none of
the vendors had like gpus in their data
centers in 2012 okay and the problem is
that this has this really fast memory
but the pipe between CPU and GPU is slow
and Still Remains slow right so the ones
that we have in our like cluster are
like 32 gigabytes a second and I've got
way faster than that and so it means
that if you're going to move something
to the GPU and do compute it better be
way way faster okay it is faster for us
to do a BFS on a big graph than it is to
transfer that graph from CPU to GPU
okay like that's just the reality of
things it's a really really slow pipe
okay so this is kind of sad like I
wasn't able to talk people into like
moving significant pieces because of
this huge overhead that we had to pay
okay so back then we had like kind of
this cute bird and then we fast forward
like uh uh six months or six years and
the birds changed a little bit shaped a
little different
um but what's really changed is we have
this enormous gorilla in the room and
that's machine learning uh and so all of
a sudden like people said like this is
what's really important right like this
is something we absolutely have to run
and we're going to put it on the GPU
because it runs really really well on
the GPU and it's worth doing this move
so it's a really different world than we
had six years before and so now
everybody's got uh gpus in the data
center and so what this has meant is
that people are really thinking hard
about how do we put everything on the
GPU okay and now Twitter is a giant
hellscape but beyond that like all the
things we want to do on graphs even if
they're not very good they're
interesting to put on the GPU okay like
it can just be on par in terms of
performance because nobody wants to move
things back to the CPU so there's a huge
investment in sort of infrastructure to
do more and more stuff on the GPU
because everybody has these data science
or machine learning pipelines where
something on the GPU is really the
Cornerstone of that pipeline can I just
ask
um how about energy consumption I mean
we live in a world where we worry about
energy and if
if you give me so many threads and they
somehow try to all stay active and they
don't do anything useful as they stand
for the environment
yeah okay so energy consumption I think
if you look at energy per op gpus do
pretty well uh and the reason is CPUs
are not very energy friendly in the
sense that all the stuff that you have
that you're paying for there's this
incredible huge bunch of control
Hardware that doesn't do math right
you've got this out of order engine all
the time that's like moving things
around if you look at a CPU die most of
it is not compute if you look at a GPU
die a lot more of it is compute and I
would I would bet if we ran the numbers
and I can find you the numbers because I
know who does the numbers in terms of
workloads uh because gpus are so much
more compute in terms of where they're
spending their energy it's better energy
per die per op
P most of you don't make much use of the
parallelism well I mean but you're not
going to use the GPU in a way that
doesn't make good use of the parallelism
so I'm assuming it's a workload that
would be parallel friendly
so I wouldn't be too nervous about your
concern there
okay
um so now we'll actually talk about
graphs a little bit uh and so academic
graph work I just want to tell you what
we do
um most academic graph work only looks
at six applications and they're really
basic applications and there's very
little compute in there it's mostly
about like traversal-ish kinds of things
and these are interesting okay but they
are not the things that people are
generally running in data centers except
evidently for pagerank which Google
seems to take really seriously but I
would say these are things you know if
you want to run a general graph workload
you need to be able to run these well
but it is not the only condition because
people are running things that are more
complicated
um in general GPU graph work at least in
the academic sense is not particularly
programmable most things that are
released sort of are do these six and
nothing more
um they're usually started with like I
have one fast implementation then I add
a bunch of knobs to it okay so that I
can like put in some different command
line parameters
um and just to tell you what those knobs
are because that's kind of interesting
the kind of stuff that we think about
that influences how fast things run load
balancing strategies are really
important okay so you have lots of fine
grain load imbalance and you need to
keep these 70 units busy so you do a lot
of moving around of work to try to get
uh regular computation even though the
input is kind of irregular so load
balancing is a big Focus are you
traversing forward or backward we look
at a lot of strategies that are like
it's cheap to do this poorly and it's
expensive to do this well okay filtering
for instance well we could do it exactly
but that's expensive but we could do a
crummy job of filtering we can do a
crummy job of uniquifying okay
um what are intermediate data
representations look like are they dense
are they sparse are they bitmaps right
so these are the kind of decisions that
we think about and I think there's a lot
of opportunity to do a more systematic
exploration of the space because I think
there's a lot of things when you say
crummy job do you mean like approximate
yes is it like
probably I mean you're doing something
that you know is going to be a good
approximation or it doesn't matter or so
am I what does a crummy job mean okay so
you niquify for instance right so you do
an advance and you're looking at all
your neighbors and you've got uh you
know
multiple uh no multiple vertices that
connect to the same vertex and so that's
coming out you come out with an output
Frontier okay you could make that
perfectly you know uniquified there's
probably another name for that
it just means to remove the duplicates
okay to turn it from a list into a set
okay or it can do a kind of bad job and
leave some duplicates in there and
that's going to mean I do a little more
work down the road because now I've got
a few extra vertices sitting in there
but if I do a really cheap uniquify
maybe that makes sense okay
okay
work with DARPA for a few years uh we
wrote a big so they had very very
different kinds of applications and so
we find these more representative we
understand these are more representative
of like what people actually run in the
real world and they're very different
than like do a BFS or single Source
Shores path so for instance just one I
want to mention seated graph matching
right so the problem they have is we're
going to give you this social graph and
it's going to be labeled with things
that we know and we're going to give you
this different social graph and it's
totally unlabeled and we think that some
of the nodes here correspond with some
of the nodes here tell us which ones
Kevin's obviously National Security
applications that come with that but
that's not single Source short shorts
path like it's a much more complicated
kind of thing in general what we found
when we looked at DARPA workloads they
were what surprised me was how
fine-grained they were in terms of like
do small parts of a graph application
just do a graph operation and then do
some other kind of compute okay whether
it be linear algebra or machine learning
or optimization or something like that
and then go back into graph they were
really fine grained
um okay and then uh
what does Nvidia do okay so Nvidia has
an ecosystem for doing graph work it's
called Rapids it's in a bigger ecosystem
that is for data science and so they
have big long pipelines that people set
up right so you know I gather in all
this data I do some like pandas kind of
processing on it I output some sort of
graph I do some graph processing I
output it to a visualization engine and
so on so graph is just a piece of this
so what they've really thought about is
like how do we move things from piece to
piece how do we make the modular what
are the data structures so their primary
data structure is a data frame okay so
like this big tabular you know something
you'd get out of a database okay what
they do all their graph computation on
is CSR they don't have anything that's
Dynamic graphed today at all what they
are interested in more than anything
else is gnns graph neural networks like
that's what their customers are asking
for they are interested in moving into
Dynamic stuff there but they haven't got
there yet
um so this is pretty simple like we have
a lot of people that come up with these
cool new brand new data structures and
that's just not practical in this sort
of
uh uh in this sort of workflow
especially because you don't get any
chance to pre-process in this workflow
when you see a graph you're seeing it
for the very first time because it's
been dynamically generated right before
it gets to you
okay so now I'm going to tell you a
little bit about Dynamic data structures
in general and what we've learned from
doing this over the last few years and
the big problem that we have is this
real chicken and egg problem right
there's no applications out there that
use GPU mutable Dynamic GPU data
structures because nobody built them
before and so when we design a cool new
data structure or Implement something
that's been done before we have
literally nothing to plug it into to say
like how's it actually going to work in
practice and because and so then it just
goes around well nobody's going to build
these data structures because there's no
use for them and then nobody's going to
build applications with them all right
so nvidia's just started building a
collections library and all it has is
set map and multi-map and they're
thinking about a dynamic map right so
we're way behind where you are in terms
of actually implementing these things in
production
and this is where you're going to get
really really creeped out as theorists
a lot of times we compare against the
data structure you have all these
beautiful data structures what we
compare against a lot is sorted arrays
right and that creeps you out rightfully
so but sort of arrays are pretty good
because you can do queries on them you
can do you know range queries on them uh
uh you know a binary search is not
terrible on a GPU you have lots of
binary searches running in uh in
parallel
and then when you mutate these arrays
you get to use GPU Primitives that are
really fast so it's emergence all right
we're really good at doing sorts and
merges so assorted arrays are not
terrible sorry about that
um something that has come up a lot is
this idea of incremental updates like
this week uh so the problem is for us to
have good Dynamic data structures we're
kind of in this Goldilocks problem which
is
if we're making these really small
changes to a graph okay it's a terrible
thing for the GPU because you're like
adding five things and you need 300 000
threads so that's not very interesting
for us if we have really big changes
then we just rebuild the data structure
from scratch right and we're pretty good
at bulk build okay we know how to do
that all that's often an interesting
problem the question is like where are
we in the middle here like do real
applications use oh I want to throw in a
hundred thousand vertices at a time or
changes okay and because of this problem
we're not really sure in practice right
this is very much if we build it
hopefully they're going to come but it
concerns us okay and we run the
experiments and we say like when does
the crossover when does it make sense to
bulk build versus doing this incremental
sort of thing as a function of graph of
uh
um as a function of a batch size and so
on and these are exactly the sort of
things we've been talking about all week
and we worry about that too
um I'll skip a few things here uh but I
also wanted to get to semantics because
this came up as well
so what do programmers really want when
you start to work in this parallel world
so it's really easy to say hey I've got
this Dynamic data structure and I have
this list of changes and we're going to
apply them one at a time and there's
this deterministic thing that's going to
come out when you apply them one at a
time okay what happens if you give a
batch of updates at a time what does the
programmer expect when that happens does
the programmer expect that they're going
to go in order
okay
well we could do that but it would take
an enormous amount of work because we
need to serialize it or at least go to a
lot of work to figure out what we can do
in parallel and so we kind of think that
maybe bulk semantics are interesting
okay the idea of I'm going to throw this
in here it's going to be consistent but
I can't make you any promises about what
order they're going to happen and then
the question is what happens when I do
additions and deletions and changes to
pieces of data what can you expect when
that ends up happening
the other thing that we're curious about
is again with real applications are they
phased are they phased in the sense of
is there an update phase and then we
stop mutating the data structure and
then we query it and we only query it
when we're not updating it
I'd say my instinct is most applications
are phased and that makes our problem a
little bit easier okay because we don't
have to worry about like making queries
while we're in some sort of
inconsistency this is an unanswered
question
for me anyway
okay so now I'm like 50 minutes in so
let me tell you about four different
things that we have done as a community
to actually do graph data structures and
I will get through this in just a few
minutes because they're not very
complicated and that's why they're going
to probably make you feel a little bit
queasy so what we start with is CSR okay
we got this list of vertices each vertex
has a bunch of neighbors we pack those
neighbors together into a dense array
awesome obviously this is really hard to
update because you know you stick in
something here you got to move a lot of
things over
so the first thing we can do is we can
say let's split those up okay this is
done in a Georgia Tech project called a
hornet
uh and so each one of these is now an
individual data structure and we keep
all of our elements in here and if we
want to put too many elements into there
then we stop we double the size of
what's there we copy things over and
continue
so that's one thing that we can choose
to do another thing we can choose to do
and this is work from uh Tu grots in
Austria and really great group over
there I really like the work that they
do and they say rather than having sort
of these arbitrary size things that keep
doubling in size we're going to instead
have these fixed size atoms and then
have a linked list of those and if we
need more then we'll just sort of append
something else on the end so you can you
know better than I do sort of what the
trade-offs are between these two things
one nice thing is you don't have to copy
if you're adding a bunch of new things
but they're both different uh different
ways to think about organizing
practically a data structure and these
both work straight
to having a fixed block size huge
advantages to having fixed block size
and I've slides on that but I'm not
going to really able to be able to cover
um the the block size that you want and
this is really the key of our hash
tables that we have built is the size of
a Warp right so uh and then we have an
entire warp making operations on the
hash table of time so our warps are like
32 big and so we have like 128 byte atom
and that's what this group is also
okay so the design choice that you have
to make here is what do you actually
store in each of these data structures
whether it be organized like this or not
and so this is where this becomes very
challenging because the question is do I
store a sorted list
or do I store an unsorted list okay if I
store an unsorted list then queries to
say is there something in the list or
very expensive because you have to walk
the whole list
okay if I store a sorted list I can do a
nice little binary search and that's
faster on the other hand I have to
maintain the list
okay both of those things are
undesirable and expensive and it kind of
depends on what your workloads are are
you doing more queries are you doing
more updates as to which one's going to
make more sense but both of those are
relatively expensive
um so we tried to avoid that um so ours
is the third way we did this we said
instead of using lists to represent
things we're instead going to use uh
hash tables and so we're going to have a
list of vertices and then each vertex
has its own hash table that stores all
of its neighbors and you know hash
tables work and you know what the
advantages and disadvantages are and so
we have previously done work that is
building fast Dynamic hash tables and we
do it by having atoms that are a
particular size that are well suited to
the GPU but these are hash tables that
are pretty close in performance to the
best static hash tables which is kind of
nice
um we think as we get large uh vertex
adjacency less than b trees might make
sense and we've done work in that too
but that's just a ton of engineering to
put together
um I have details on the hash table not
going to really cover that right now but
what we uh one of the contributions we
made here is to start thinking about how
do you evaluate these because again we
don't have Dynamic graph applications on
the GPU and it was nice to hear about
some of the ways you guys are generating
dynamic graphs for instance taking
something with temporal and then sort of
walking through time like that makes a
lot of sense we were a little lost in
terms of what these data structures
could be uh Sandia has a benchmark
called fire hose I think and that seemed
interesting but in general we need to
know as a community more about these
data structures
um guy blelek sort of talked about his
different models for what these should
look like we thought about sort of
individual benchmarks on low-level stuff
we thought about how you do Global
builds and then we thought about
applications and we sort of talked about
what each of these levels should have in
terms of evaluations
um you know DARPA for instance was
saying one of the scenarios we should
think about they called it add an age so
they said basically what we want is like
a fixed size data set that you're
changing over time you keep throwing new
things in but every time you throw new
things in you get rid of the oldest
things okay and that was consistent with
one of the things that guy said uh in
his talk on Tuesday
okay uh cool so uh one of the benefits
of this is just much faster to build
it's a lot faster to build hash tables
than it is to do that sorting problem of
basically sorting each one of these
things individually you do this big
segmented sort but it's much faster for
us to build our hash tables so that was
a win
the last data structure that's been done
is Like An Early Access paper on IEEE
tkde right now which is something we
heard about in the last couple days uh
building a packed memory array this is
an enormous engineering effort to make
this work on the GPU but it's a nice
data structure for this right the
theoretical bounds as I understand them
are favorable for some of the operations
that we'd really like to be able to do
um what they hung their hat on in terms
of performance was uh what they called a
static neighbor I'm sorry assorted
neighbor query they felt that it was
important to be able to ask the data
structure to give you the lit the
neighbors for any particular vertex and
that that be sorted and I'm a little
skeptical because I don't know
applications that require sorting okay
if you give it to me and it's unsorted
I'm cool with that I mean there might be
some locality reasons but obviously a
PMA is going to give you something
sorted whereas a hash table will not
um anyway there's some good work on
doing pmas it's pretty recent and I
think uh I'm excited to see more work in
this direction
so what I think is important for uh
what comes next like for our community
we need to understand workloads better
and I don't think we've done a really
good job of that
I'm interested in just building more
data structures and I kind of look and
say these seem cool and maybe they would
be great on the GPU I think persistent
data structures are neat and I think a
lot of the data structures that are used
in some of the functional programming uh
uh literature are also neat but I don't
know if they're a great fit now but I
would be excited to learn more about
them I would love to hear data
structures from you
uh one of the worries we have is like
are the apis that we have like the right
kind of apis and so if we have a higher
level language than Cuda maybe we kind
of hide that and we can build something
that works very nicely within a
particular
language where we can hide the details
of like how we actually access it and
then be able to build languages that
have uh you know good data structures
underneath them and the other thing
we're looking into is a lot of these
data structure problems sort of involve
maintenance of some kind doing garbage
collection or deleting all the
Tombstones or rebalancing or whatever
and so we're thinking about GP runtimes
they might be able to sort of do that
alongside other data structure kind of
applications
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much for a great talk any
question
I mean this is very philosophical now
but so I'd like to understand what also
in terms of community what do you think
is the difference between algorithms
engineering and systems engineering yeah
so
the stuff that I'm talking about here I
would call that algorithm engineering
right the kind of papers we've written
on data structures I I think it's the
right kind of fit
um
I think when we are building something
that doesn't involve interesting or
novel ways to think about data
structures and algorithms maybe then it
gets to a little bit more systems uh but
I think the stuff I've talked about
today I I put it in that category
that's worked for us in terms of
publication strategy as well like
there's there's a community that's
interested in this kind of work and
understands we're not doing new
algorithms we're maybe thinking about
how do they map best and how do we make
them run fast
so like I like to go to parallel
Computing kinds of things so like uh
ppop or ipdps are really good parallel
Computing conferences that have uh
interest in
algorithmic engineering like ipdps has
specifically I think a a track that is
algorithmic engineering
um I'm trying to think Royal streams
like an alanx kind of thing
um and then we had a paper last year
like a hash table paper that was in on
another name it was in Italy in like
January
probably
no one knows a box that's right apocs so
like that seemed like a good fit too
and so which communities do you reach in
these conferences because I mean
elevates the sort of call to be internal
to the algorithms Community yeah but uh
if you actually are more interested in
telling the rest of the world here's
actual algorithm that's useful so if
it's more with a systems Focus then I'm
going to go to a more parallel Computing
conference like a p-pop or an ipdps or
something like that
um I will say that one of the weird
things about the GPU Community is we
don't really have a home
okay there isn't like this is where we
do all the best GPU work and that's both
good and bad it's good because it's it's
bad because like you always have to
convince people like Hey we're part of
your community it is good because you're
publishing in a lot of different places
and so it gets you perhaps a broader
audience
foreign
so if as an algorithm person I want to
do research that is helpful for you what
would you suggest I mean it's the first
thing to think about a model even so it
might be very complicated
um that you approve of and then start to
think of no it makes no sense if you
don't think it makes sense but the and
then start thinking of developing
algorithms in that direction for that
model or
how would one go about yeah I think I
would start like we have done well with
theorists saying hey you don't have
these at all and here's this cool thing
we've thought of that seems to be
parallel friendly and you know we have
huge missing chunks out of the space of
what we've implemented like hash tables
seem like a useful thing to have okay
how do we think about it what is the
kind of formulation that makes sense
like here's all these things but like
cuckoo hashing that seems to have some
good properties can we map that well and
so it's sort of like where are the holes
and but it's a lot of times people
saying hey there's this recent work in
this that I did or that I know about in
this community that actually seems to be
practical and people have done
interesting implementations or just the
bounds are good and it's really parallel
friendly is this something that would
seem like it would be something to do on
the GPU
um I think things that work the
parallelism I think is the hard part
right so a lot of pram algorithms map
well but it doesn't really have any
conception of locality and that makes
things a little bit tough and so I think
there's more advanced models that take
that into account but starting with
something that's parallel friendly is by
far the most important thing
that answer your question
any more questions
okay let's thank Johns again thanks a
lot
[Applause]